a superhero quoting a warmongering vice
president a hilarious evil dance routine
and perhaps the worst batman moment of
all time here are a few times that dc
movies made us cringe
it's probably fair to say that gal gadot
is not exactly recognized as one of her
generation's masters of the theatrical
arts some might argue that's okay after
all her iteration of wonder woman relies
on physicality and charisma much more
than spending the audience's disbelief
indeed when she does come off as a
little disconnected that actually helps
her project a sense of otherworldliness
but every once in a while gadot delivers
some good old-fashioned bad acting her
infamous overwrought reprimand of a
rampaging superman in both the 2017 and
the 2021 versions of justice league
serves as a case in point of course
wonder woman's decision to call superman
by his kryptonian birth name at this
point seems odd in itself seeing as how
basically nobody from earth calls him
that but the real shocker here is
gadot's line read both justice league
movies include different takes of wonder
woman's warning
[Music]
kalel no
halal no
and neither of them are good this might
suggest that the writers ought to share
some of the blame for this particular
blunder but let's face it good dot is
hardly helping
this is a scene that'll be talked about
for decades but not for the reasons dc
once hoped in 2016's batman vs superman
dawn of justice batman is about to
impale superman on a kryptonite spear
and then
you're letting him
kill martha
him refers to lex luthor who has taken
martha kent hostage martha as an
abstract concept provides a basis for
thoughtful analysis of gender in zack
snyder's dcu films that said even though
her kidnapping provides superman's
motivation at this point martha barely
seems like she's in this movie at all
until
save
martha
this cosmic coincidence forces batman to
hesitate allowing enough time for lois
lane to show up and explain luther's
evil plot and sure in some parallel
universe there may exist a version of
this scene that isn't cringe-worthy
after all the idea does make sense it's
just a shame the execution leaves so
much to be desired
when vice president dick cheney left
office in 2009 his administration's
approval rating had sunk into the low
20s so should a beloved hero like batman
parrot such a hugely divisive and
retired politician dawn of justice seems
to think so
he has the power to wipe out the entire
human race and if we believe there's
even a one percent chance that he is our
enemy we have to take it as an absolute
certainty
somebody clearly thought this quote was
so apt that they even included it in the
film's trailer but folks who remember
post 911 american politics might notice
that batman borrowed an infamous cheney
quote there partly verbatim in 2003 the
ex-veep had said if there's a one
percent chance that pakistani scientists
are helping al-qaeda build or develop a
nuclear weapon we have to treat it as a
certainty in terms of our response
this argument was used by cheney in 2003
as justification for the us invasion of
iraq here batman vs superman puts a
widely disliked man's words about a
wildly unpopular war in the mouth of one
of the most popular heroes in all of
fiction whatever the intent for the
purpose of the story it feels like a
serious misfire
though it's never stated outright it's
very heavily implied that in batman vs
superman lex luthor pees in a jar and
leaves it on a podium as a final screw
you to senator june finch this happens
just moments before a suicide bomber
kills her along with an entire courtroom
of people doesn't this seem a little
juvenile and crass even for jesse
eisenberg's bizarre take on luther based
on his mannerisms and background this
version of luther scans like a
combination of eisenberg's performance
in the social network and a mediocre
screenwriter who once made a youtube fan
film about superman even still you can't
help but wonder if the movie version of
mark zuckerberg would have come up with
a more elegant and sophisticated way to
mess with senator finch's brain before
blasting her to smithereens he did
invent facebook after all
the version of jonathan kent portrayed
by kevin costner and man of steel is a
man who loves farming and hates rescuing
people when they're in trouble this
makes him a somewhat non-traditional
interpretation of clark kent's
foundational male role model who in
other takes on the superman myth tends
to gently push clark in a more
pro-saving people direction
no ifs ands or buts about it the moment
when famously invincible clark kent
stands by and watches his adopted dad
run into a raging tornado to rescue the
family dog only to predictably die
horribly is very cringy obviously
superman could rescue his paw and the
pooch very quickly and with minimal
effort but instead he just stands there
and does this
and if you think that's bad wait until
you hear superman's cry of exhausted
anguish immediately after offing zod at
the end of the movie
[Applause]
but hey maybe this is just how superman
reacts to bad stuff missed the bus
colors ran in the wash
[Applause]
out of milk
or old clark kent just can't catch a
break
barbara minerva is one of the most
glaring missed opportunities in wonder
woman 1984. there have been a few
different versions of cheetah in the
comics but the baseline of barbara can
be summarized as the answer to the
question what if indiana jones was an
evil flesh-eating jungle cat but instead
of a physical and mental match for an
immortal amazon princess wonder woman
1984 coughs up an awkward nerd who loses
her mind when she gets powers in the
mold of some of joel schumacher's batman
villains when barbara and diana meet
barbara's deeply envious of diana
because
something to do with her self-esteem
even though barbara is also a
conventionally attractive woman with a
fancy archaeology career that presumably
pays very handsomely indeed still at
least she looks good in her cheetah form
the general consensus on the two
versions of justice league is that zack
snyder's revamped version of the movie
released in 2021 is a step up from the
2017 theatrical cut but that doesn't
mean the so-called snyder cut is totally
free of cringe-worthy moments take for
instance the whole deal with martha kent
and lois lane after ma kent finishes
telling lois lane that she can't grieve
over superman's death forever martha
leaves the apartment then suddenly
transforms into jon jones also known as
the martian manhunter jones in his dceu
debut then transforms again into general
calvin swanwick who you may remember
from man of steel martian manhunter
never interacts directly with any
justice league members until well after
the major events of the film have
wrapped up he comes across as totally
unconnected to the plot and feels
shoehorned in for the purpose of showing
the audience yet another familiar
intellectual property furthermore he
raises some befuddling questions the
film never addresses for one was harry
lennox who plays general swanwick
playing jon jones all the way back in
man of steel or did jon replace that guy
at some point that's not the only
problem with this scene either setting
aside whether you accept the idea that
lois would completely fall apart after
superman's demise the kind of serious
clinical depression she is suffering
from isn't the sort of thing that gets
resolved by a pep talk from your almost
mother-in-law all in all a decent scene
for fanservice but not so much for
anything else
in one of the most talked about
additions to justice league's 2021
snyder cut the film's plot flashes
forward to a potential future one in
which batman and a cohort of costumed
pals wander through a mad max style
wasteland it soon becomes clear that
this gang includes the joker played by
jared leto reprising his suicide squad
rule a subsequent conversation between
batman and the joker dumps the
exposition of their relationship
basically batman can never kill the
joker because they complete each other
or something it's the usual song and
dance but then joker says this
he won't kill me
i'm your best friend
besides
who's gonna give you a reach around
oh boy that's right this ain't your
grandpa's joker this one is dark and
scary and kinda homophobic too
eat your heart out zac elephanakis and
sure some folks like the joker stuff and
zack snyder's justice league all power
to them but you'd also be forgiven for
thinking it plays like a 13 year old
read the killing joke saw the dark
knight and then decided to write a
batman joker scene that was the edgiest
thing to ever have an edgy night in
edgeville of course the scene also makes
basically no sense and adds nothing to
the larger context of the movie but it
is at least noteworthy for its
vindication of joel schumacher who is no
longer responsible for the worst batman
moment of all time
thanks to the runaway success of james
guns 2021 the suicide squad the david
ayer directed original suicide squad is
likely to fade away into obscurity still
we'll always have the memories like
these early promotional stills for the
film that set jared leto up to fail
miserably as the successor to heath
ledger's turn as the clown prince of
crime
before you realized what you were
looking at you might have been forgiven
for wondering why ayer had chosen to
promote his suicide squad movie with
that guy who got kicked out of the mall
for taking his shirt off in spencer's or
maybe you wondered why jared leto had
started a metal core band but then the
horrible truth docked oh man that's
supposed to be the joker
it wasn't a great moment
here's a fun fact for you belly dancing
is not intimidating if you have ever
been to a belly dancing demonstration
you'll notice that the performers in no
way intend to frighten the audience so
when the minds behind suicide squad
needed something for enchantress to do
to indicate that some evil as heck magic
was taking place why did they land on
this
it's clear that somebody at warner
brothers thought audiences would react
better to a runway model dancing in her
underwear rather than say
anything that actually made sense
but this is suicide squad's main
antagonist someone who is supposed to be
a big bad reality destroying super
villain shouldn't she be doing anything
more disturbing than shaking her hips to
some medium quality cg effects
honestly enchantress's whole deal in
suicide squad feels like somebody in
charge was working overtime to appeal to
the teenage male segment of the audience
which would explain what they did to
harley quinn too
thanks to the advancement of science and
technology it's more or less common
amongst human beings to carry around
what is essentially a computer in their
pockets amazing right and yet hollywood
still seems unable to edit one mustache
off one guy in one movie
[Applause]
back in 2017 a tragic family emergency
forced original director zack snyder to
leave the production of what became the
theatrical cut of justice league the now
notorious joss whedon took over from
there to basically nobody's satisfaction
by the time the whedon helmed reshoots
began however henry cavill had grown a
mustache for his part in mission
impossible fallout this meant that the
justice league special effects team had
to digitally erase caval's facial hair
in post-production by the time justice
league hit theaters the extensive
reshoots and digital edits had been
widely reported in the media so it's
hard to say if anyone would have noticed
the change if they weren't looking for
it sadly it happened to be the case that
everybody was in fact looking for a
digitally altered upper lip that came
straight out of bizarro world as a
result everybody did notice it and the
ensuing laughter could be heard all
around the world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
the dc eu are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you